come on come on work
you
I think rive really is there the audio
is there I I hear it
oh yeah the chat exploded which seems
promising here here have been just
reading your questions and not being
able to answer them fast enough but you
know I can't yeah this is gonna be a
little nuts okay so hi Nick hi Diana
long time no see yeah except for the
past half hour or everything staring at
each other going what did you do what
did you finally do this um I I went I
went back into the stream settings on
YouTube and i refresh them oh that's it
just refreshing doing so then we start a
meeting refreshing it's like that thing
like did you turn it off and on it
always applies Oh
joke about the universe like turning it
off and on right now because there's a
lot of things going wrong yes so here we
are we're live audio and everything
everybody can hear us yeah it seems like
it okay so so yeah this is this is yes I
I guess I don't know there's people here
that know you and there's people here
that know me so yeah that's true well
this is your this is your channel Thanks
right most people know who you are more
than me so so yeah so I wanted to do
whoops I wanted to do a live stream have
some fun with everybody and now that
we're like you know half an hour later
that we're supposed to
we should be able to get this thing
started uh I am for those of you don't
know me I'm Nick lucid I do stuff on
this channel the science asylum where I
play it you know I'm a crazy guy uh but
uh I do I mean my I do a lot of
different videos but my expertise is in
relativity general relativity which I'm
excited to have started a series on
recently oh very exciting expertise for
a while now it is but I think I I think
when you know it's that you know close
to you it just you want to do it right
and then you're afraid you can't and so
I think I just put it off I think that's
way you know um interestingly I there's
a there's a topic that's near and dear
to me which is the struggles that women
have to face the only time I'm going to
talk about this in this livestream
promised the struggles that women have
had to face in the sciences and it's
something that I really care about so I
don't talk a lot about because it's like
like you got to do it the right way
because there are real struggles and
then there are there are not real
struggles and and so like really really
talking about them the right way I think
is important anyways yeah and so I think
I think with what general relativity
it's just it was a matter of me feeling
confident in it I guess
I kind of had impostor syndrome for a
while and having the ability to do the
animations that I want you know I have a
certain way I want it to look and if I
can't get it to look that way then I I'm
just not gonna do it
and so I've only recently felt felt like
I I had developed the skills for it yeah
it's easier to marry off your your least
favorite child right just like that you
know how many kids right I do not
obviously right I just have Lego Lego
scientists
I have a niece oh that's cute I've got I
have six nephews and one nice the rest
of my siblings got got busier than I
sure I think I'm gonna enjoy being an
alcoholic it's it's gonna be fun a new
niece uh yeah she's a year and a half
nice introducing her to that general
relativity series right yeah yeah you
know got to start them while they're
young so how are you how are the
questions gonna work for this by the way
I'm Diana Nick rain reduce me but sorry
sorry yeah so this is Diana uh if you
don't know her where are your interests
oh my interests well physics obviously
Oh specifically in physics yes within
physics I think fluid dynamics is one of
my favorite topics but I think that's
that's been since making videos because
there there's just some really visually
stunning and fascinating fluid dynamics
experiments in general I am big fan of
astrophysics looking up at the stars
that's got me that's what got me really
into science and physics originally and
then and then particle physics it's kind
of cool cuz you get to smash things and
optics oh I think that was my favorite
in college cuz we got to make Holograms
and learn how Holograms work in lasers
and I think there's something really
fascinating about about electricity and
magnetism and then as it relates to
waves through light sure yeah I had I
took I took optics in undergrad and I I
had a teacher that really he really
cared about
students and he wanted them to learn but
he he was used to like he was older and
so he was he was used to you know back
in the day when you know students in the
classroom would be more interactive and
everything and so when no one would you
know he'd ask a question and no one
would answer and he would just move on
and it he started to have trouble like
staying focused and he'd kind of
developed this this reputation for being
a bad teacher but he wasn't I mean he
cared you know and so um one time I went
I went to his office hours and no one
ever goes to anyone's office hours but I
went to his office hours that I had a
conversation with him you know I was
like I don't really understand what's
going on here you know and we had a
conversation and it was so much better
and so then I realized that like he just
needs the he needs to like interface
with people yeah and so I just started
like answering his questions in class
and asking questions in class and you
know people give me these weird looks
they turn around what do you do but then
the lectures were so much better that's
that's crazy I feel I feel like that's
one of the things this is like a lesson
but can be generalized to a lot of
professors which is that they're really
good at learning science and then doing
science and then they're thrown into
teaching and there's such a an expertise
that comes over time or that maybe
people will never be that into but right
yeah it's interesting that like that as
the student you found his trick I wonder
if he carried that on into other classes
hopefully I there is a question that
went by which is how long who did you
study and you went on to do some
postgraduate work I stopped at my
undergrad I did my undergrad physics at
MIT and then did a little bit of
research
afterwards in astrophysics and then
started moving on in
I was actually applying to grad school I
was doing the gr I think I told you this
me GRE yeah I was doing the GRE and I
took the general one and then I was like
I don't want to study for the physics
GRE and that's the reason I didn't go to
grad school because it was over it I was
over studying anymore I there's some
regrets I have when I go to grad school
like I ended up doing this it it
eventually led on to this so I can't
complain right yeah I did I did a
master's yes and and so I had to take
the the general GRE but I did have to
take the physics one because the place I
applied didn't require it and I was like
I'm not gonna take it then I don't want
to take the test I think maybe I was
aiming too high I was like I wasn't
required it should aim lower I did I
didn't go to it I didn't go to a big
school so it wasn't no we're not aimed
lower I think it's more like like aimed
smarter because the colleges that are
not using the GR you know are starting
to recognize that it doesn't actually in
any way correlates to your success as a
scientist like your skills doing
research your skills taking classes they
don't correlate your successes in
correlating grad school with the GRE
scores that you had so yeah and I went
to I went to grad school the same place
I went to undergrad so it wasn't like
everybody knew me and they were just
like just take the general GRE well
let's just approve it'll be fine good
luck Maxine who's studying for the GRE
now oh yeah good luck it's it's not it's
not as bad as it it it sounds going in I
I had issues with it cuz it was timed
and I don't I don't do well on time
tests yeah yeah what dude there are too
many questions I know there's ippon by
really fast uh I guess I guess we should
probably stop you know reminiscing and
and take some of these questions
they've waited long enough let's see we
can scooch it if you scooch the chat up
off the bottom a little bit it'll it'll
stop scrolling nice are you guys chest
nerds I like that question I never got
into chess oh yeah hey do you play any
games neck I I never I never got like
real big into chess I mean I learned to
play it uh and I wanted to get big into
it and I got like you know this actually
when I was I was high school I collected
this I like collected a bunch of like
pewter pieces and like a marble chess
board and everything and I wanted it to
be just like cool thing I still have the
chess board
but I don't I don't ever play it it's
not out I don't have a lot of room and
yeah I put it out but I I it's I mean
it's it's normal sized it's not huge
yeah but they take up table space they
do care like mount it on the wall and
play great Elysium magnets I guess I'll
be kind of a cool that would be I wonder
if that would change people's strategy
or affect how they play if you had to
play sideways on the wall yeah I may be
where I mean you'd have to take like
would you be on the sides or on the top
and the bottom I don't know I don't know
I feel like I feel like sides I don't
know
besides sides might be more fair are
there any let's see what is your
favorite quantum mechanics
interpretation oh boy well I don't know
if I have a favorite I have
interpretations that I have issues with
and okay so that they're first there are
a lot that have been ruled out by this
point a lot fewer than where around in
like 1926 but you know there's only a
few left but I don't like
I know everybody gets obsessed with
pilot waves pilot wave model and it I
just can't I can't get into it cuz I
can't uh I can't let go of locality I
just can't do it my head and I'm gonna
tell you why okay because as an
undergrad you could do physics where you
take like the three quantum mechanics
classes or you do physics where you do a
focus and something else I did that and
took the one quantum mechanics class and
then I focused intellectual engineering
so I could talk to you a whole lot more
about capacitors and transistors yeah
but I but I'm great at asking questions
so let me ask you this I didn't know
that there were like a lot of
interpretations of quantum mechanics and
here's where I slip into my expertise
which is being curious I didn't know
that there were a lot of quantum
mechanics interpretations in the 20s
that are that are now gone
I'm tell us about that Nick okay I guess
a little a little conversation about
this so um quantum mechanics is based on
just a bunch of probability math right
and yes so there's this this quantum
wave function which actually I did a
video about a few months ago but um
basically the the idea is there are
these these interpretations where you
have to be able to look at I mean this
is something we do in all physics right
you want to look at numbers that you've
calculated using models and you want to
be able to say something about the
universe right do and typically you want
to be able to do a test right and then
rule out theories right and so we would
like to be able to do that in quantum
mechanics as well and so when we get
some kind of number some probability we
want to be able to like look at that
number and be like well this says this
about the system mm-hmm and the problem
is when you're working with probability
and statistics there's a lot of
different interpretations
it's a lot of ways you can like well
what does this number actually mean hmm
and so back in the day back in the 1920s
when we first were developing this we we
didn't we had a lot with a huge list of
possible interpretations some people
thought that this was you know
fact that only probabilities worked on a
quantum level meant that that it was it
was some new thing that we didn't
understand and it was we couldn't
understand it was just weird and then
other people were like no no no it's
it's fine it's just showing our lack of
knowledge it doesn't mean that the
universe is weird and so that this
argument began and so
you know the question comes down to like
well what is the quantum wave function
and and we still we still don't know
there there are some that we've ruled
out we've ruled out a lot of what we
call hidden variable interpretation
right and so those are ones were like
well no those properties the particles
have those properties we just don't we
just can't measure them for whatever yes
yeah and we're clever enough to come up
with like was it Bell Bell yeah Joseph
Bell I think got my memories so bad but
yeah people have come up with the most
creative ways to rule out different
theories on quantum mechanics so I feel
I find this fascinating in and of itself
that like just the concept of
interpretations that you've got you have
you've got like quantum mechanics which
is a set of I don't know mathematical
rules and principles that describe how
the quantum world the very very small
world works but then there are
interpretations of that which I find to
be a fascinating concept in and of
itself that like we we have had to
interpret what all that math means
because we can't even like we can't
conceive of it like we have right her
predict we feel like it's almost like a
translation it is like an interpreter
like a translator into some into like
concepts that we can understand which is
why there's there's interpretations like
the many worlds or many I think that's
what's called many many worlds like that
where like you open shorteners cat the
box that shooting is cat is in and the
BOK the cat's either alive or dead but
that interpretation says that it's not
actually it's not actually alive or dead
when you open it you actually create
another universe where in one universe
the cat is alive and the other cat is
dead and the thing is interpretations
like that are rolled out by doing tests
right that seems like a hard one to test
if there's a second universe created in
which you cannot wander and go test
because you're in your own universe yeah
so
I don't I I don't know that I have a
favorite interpretation I have a least
favorite which is that one right I do I
don't like it either I not a fan but
it's still but like it's still around
because people are still because you
can't rule it out but as a non quantum
physicist is somebody who's not at the
level where like people are still duking
it out like like physicists are still
coming up with ways to experiment and
coming up with new theories and those
are people who have done a whole lot
more studying and have gone a lot
further in physics and specifically in
quantum mechanics so so they still are
coming up with ways new theories and way
so like how am I supposed to come up
with a favorite interpretation besides
just like what sounds nice to me I think
I think that's really the the sort of
the spirit of the question though yeah
what what what feels right to you well
certainly not yeah Sean Carroll is
certainly not that one here's the next
question
Diana and Nick diana has two ends by the
way that's the only time will be sassy I
promise I'm thinking of becoming an
astrophysicist or astronomer I'm afraid
I won't get a job after grad school
shout out to Anne and with two N's is it
a risky degree and job to have oh yeah
it's it's tough to say yes I mean it
depends on mr. astronomer yeah the thing
is like if you're aiming to become an
astrophysicist rahmanir it's a certainly
not a risky degree it's the degree that
you want in order to be an
astrophysicist very shown right if you
want to go on and do something else a
lot of the skills are really what's the
word I'm looking for commutative commute
like you can use them elsewhere right a
lot of a lot of the skills are
transferrable that seems like a good
word that's a better word to to a lot of
other fields like you can go on into
software engineering very easily because
you have to learn programming in a lot
of the classes you do and if you're at a
school where you don't learn software
engineering shame on that
because you have to learn to code for
for a lot of science and tech jobs
nowadays yeah that's my answer I think I
think yeah I think it depends on you
know what you're going for cuz I I know
people who went and they got a degree
because they thought it was gonna you
know get them a good job and and then
they were miserable the entire time they
were going through and then they're like
I don't even want a job in this and so
when I was going through undergrad
particularly um I made sure that I was
doing something that I was enjoying so
that if for whatever reason I didn't get
a job in physics I still kind of enjoyed
the ride um that's not something you I
guess you want to do if you're doing a
PhD you kind of want to have a plan in
place yeah yeah what is your favorite
computer language have you done much
programming Nick uh yeah so I was
actually I majored in computer science
before I switched to physics oh snap
so I have I have a background I guess
you could say but I did I did a lot of
programming in high school that's cool
yeah and so I think there was qbasic
which is you know the thing that
everybody's well everybody did start on
back in the day I don't know if anyone
uses it anymore and then that went on
like that was sophomore year and then
junior year was C++ and then senior year
was Java and so like I learned a lot of
these things mm-hmm and then later on
like as an adult I started I learned a
lot of HTML and Python and it's kind of
just a hobby now yeah um but I love I
love Python it's so easy that's what I
learned on I learned on Python when I
got to college I think it was a
sophomore junior at MIT and I and they
the intro classes were in Python and
then a lot of the the intro by the way
shout-out to open
forswear at MIT they have a lot of their
classes just online and available which
are awesome and as a student there
we used OpenCourseWare all the time
which I didn't expect like we would go
we would take our normal classes and
then we'd go on to the website where
they had old classes available and
learned from those if there was ever a
teacher kind of like you were talking
about Nick where they did they weren't
great
in lecture we'd go back in the old
lectures or lecture notes I love this
question why this time seemed to flow in
one direction I have no idea you answer
for that
I have a kind of a half answer I guess
I'm not I don't know enough about this
to be absolutely sure but I understand
that there there are some quantum
phenomena that go the other way
mm-hmm than it is it is possible in
quantum mechanics for things to go the
other way through time it just doesn't
seem that that's how things work on like
a normal scale yeah and I'm not sure
where the disconnect is or how that
happens but um it's it judging from that
all I can take from that is that well
this is just it just appears to be the
you know the arrow of time yeah actually
really there yeah what I've heard that
I've heard that too these quantum
mechanical processes that go backwards
my question is why it can't I like when
somebody asks a question about time why
don't I remember those factoids like you
did I'm impressed
like oh yeah yeah no I know about those
processes it's probably actually
actually what's-his-face Alan Guth
there's a physics professor I used to
have a lot of chats with about the
nature of reality and time he was a
cosmologists he is still a cosmologists
he's still with us okay he did he came
up with inflation theory which is like
if a theory right after the Big Bang
where there is this period of and really
really intense expansion and the theory
explains a lot of our observations but
again
we were talking about testing there's
not great ways to test it although there
there are some there was a did you do
you remember this like bicep2 experiment
where we thought we saw polarization and
the light from from the CMB yeah yeah
yeah I remember this this is a quick
little detour of a story there was
biceps he was the name of an experiment
carried out down and I think Antarctica
where there's a lot less light pollution
and stuff and they were looking at light
from the Cosmic Microwave Background
like the very first light that could
that ever was able to travel through the
universe when the universe cooled down
enough for a light to start traveling
across and and we were we supposedly
were seeing polarization meaning like
the direction that the light waves were
pointed or we're all aligned in certain
places are on the sky which would
indicate I don't know the details of the
theory but supposedly this would support
inflation theory I'm guessing that means
like if we saw a polarization of light
from one direction the same as another
direction in two parts of the sky that
haven't had enough time to talk to each
other then there had to have been this
period of intense inflation so the so
the that's what they thought they saw
but in fact it was dust and I don't know
if it was in the galaxy or like the
intergalactic medium but it was dust
impacting the direction the light which
is really really sad bummer
it's doing astrophysics is hard because
that is I know I was I was reading about
I was reading about you know like when
we're trying to measure the sizes of
galaxies were yeah we have to we have to
know how far away they are so that we
can judge for the brightness you know
what an average how many stars are there
and so if we can't properly judge the
distance then we don't know how big they
are and so like sometimes we'll think oh
well there's this impossibly large
galaxy or an impossibly small galaxy and
then it turns out we just have the
distance wrong and it's actually
dude I read an article the other day
that was like about adjusting the size
of the the I don't know why I said I
read the article I read the headline I'm
an article yes I too can be one of those
people from time to time but the point
of it was that that it was adjusting the
size of the Milky Way galaxy and we've
thought for a long time it was a hundred
thousand light-years across
and now I think that it was saying I
don't you guys can google this fact
check I think it was it was something
like a factor of one-and-a-half like
it's now we're thinking that it's 150
thousand light years across
don't quote me google it before you
share that information with anyone else
my point is if that's the case a hundred
and fifty thousand light years versus
100 thousand light years
like that is our own galaxy and that's a
difference of fifty thousand light years
that's 50 thousand years that light
would have to travel and light travels
really goddamn fast
sorry that was intense really damn fast
really really fast so that's that's a
big error like if you were like if
you're like I'm gonna make a mug but I'm
gonna get my my width of my mug off by
fifty thousand light years you're gonna
run out of material
halfway through the handle it's crazy
yeah that's those are the skills of
Astrophysical measurements and then it's
it's it's difficult I got a question
that I think it says what was um
somebody said that Fineman mentioned
that's that anti particles travel back
in time and what's the deal with that
not really they they do in Fineman
diagrams right so find my diagrams are
basically space-time diagrams there from
relativity and in order to make those
work
properly you have to draw anti particles
as if they're going back in time it's
just sort of like the notation but not
even not even Richard Fineman thought
the particles were actually going back
in time he didn't think that that was a
valid interpretation of his diagrams now
it might turn out in the future that
that they they do that they're actually
just particles traveling backwards in
time but but I mean it's certainly
consistent with some of the symmetries
we see in quantum mechanics I think but
I don't think most most particle
physicists don't actually think that
that's a legitimate thing I'm getting
some into my next meeting I'm trying to
push it back a little bit
uuuuu book to be back to back with
somebody yeah I mean it's been back spec
we've got it we actually the video
coming out hopefully tomorrow so there's
a lot of a lot going on well it's always
busy time but yeah so I'm trying to push
that one back a little bit so we can
keep talking for a couple more minutes
but I do have two idea you have to go
yeah pretty soon let's take a couple
like really really quick questions yes
oh this one why why is it the particles
of that an electric charge have a spin I
suspect it's because overall they have
no charge well the thing about about
particles with charges that they are
made of smaller particles that do have
fractions of charge so there's that
sticking acceleration as well so I guess
like what the question is how can
particles without charge have spin yes I
think right they're separate things it's
like how can a particle with without
without charge have weight
I was trying to think of a specific
particle how can i protocol with with
momentum have no mass right like a
photon mm-hmm they're not they're
separate things mm-hmm
now a lot of times we measure spin as a
magnetic moment and so it's not going to
have a magnetic moment without a charge
mm yes uh well I mean neutrons do
because like you said they're made of
smaller particles that do have charge
but like elementary particles like
neutrinos have a spin and they don't
have a magnetic moment because they're
not charged and so I don't think that's
it's there's no reason why they wouldn't
you know be able to have spin yeah have
you studied instead I'm not sure if that
was referring to
none of these are quick questions yeah
um let's see what what does a photon see
it doesn't see anything right everything
measured in what you might call a
photons frame of reference I hate saying
that because it doesn't really have one
but everything along a path that a
photon would take in space-time is has
has zero length and it's one of the
weirdest things in relativity and I will
do a video on this in much more detail
you should also do a video about this
one how do the exchange of bosons cause
force this is something that vexed me
for a very long time I kept asking like
okay so you've got this people I was
getting my physics degree people would
talk about force carriers so like they
talk about about a proton and an
electron so those attract each other or
an electron electron those repel each
other
and a photon is exchanged between the
two and that's the carrier of the force
between the two and so the analogy some
professors gave me was like okay so you
imagine that an electron is repelling an
electron it exchanges a photon it bumps
into it and like they repel I'm like
okay so that breaks down if you've got a
photon and an electron where they're
attracting each other so I think the
better way to think about it which which
is which starts to get into like where
you have to interpret and you can't wrap
your head around the reality of things
but the better way to think about it is
of everything all of the forces and
charges being fields that permeate all
of space and then there are particles
that travel through the fields in their
peaks in the field oh yeah I've actually
been I've been trying to read a quantum
field theory textbook because then I
never took a class on it and so I'm
trying to to teach myself and it yeah
it's so hard the intuition is what's
hard I think like there's like its kind
of its kind of like you can wrap your
head around around what these what these
physicists are saying and what they've
measured but the intuition for that
being how the world works for me is
where were you and I have issues with
the notation like like if I'm looking at
a mathematical equation I want to be
able to look at it be like okay this is
saying this in English mm-hm
and I can't do that with with qft I just
yep it's so alien okay maybe two more
quick questions okay oh I can answer
this one
where did antimatter go after the Big
Bang the end the answer is that we don't
know that is one of the biggest
unanswered questions that the largest
lab in the world which is CERN the Large
Hadron Collider is looking into it's one
of the big unanswered questions like we
don't know there should be a balanced
amount of antimatter and matter in the
world but like most of the things that
we see it's all matter its regular
matter so we don't know yet
I love those questions or it's like we
don't know right there's one that says
why do photons lose energy when they
travel through space that one is
interesting so it has to do with it has
to do that with the fact that like as
space expands the photons get stretched
out and photon well so the wave the
light waves get stretched out and
wavelengths that are longer have lower
energy so on these cosmic scales energy
is not conserved yes and this is this is
the that's the the topic we were talking
about what like a month or two ago yeah
yeah about how the how the the
stretching of space leads to the
stretching of light waves which is
actually quite a complicated it is it's
wild okay I've actually I should go okay
Nick yeah maybe we can do this again
sometime yet but no difficulties we know
now to just restart everything right
thanks everybody
I mean if you want to keep going good
don't let me stop you guys yeah well
we'll see I usually go an hour on these
but I'm like I'm gonna go another ten
minutes we'll see okay cool cool
I unfortunately do have said yeah it's
okay I understand this video is
currently at 17 and a half minutes so
[Laughter]
thank you for having me
yeah and anytime good good luck in the
quarantine times yes you too and bye see
you later
alright so let's see sorry about all the
technical difficulties but here we are
um at least you we got to talk to her
for about twenty minutes uh we get a lot
of a lot of questions in here let's see
see what we got
maybe I can answer some of these bigger
ones before we go what classes do you
teach Nick I don't anymore actually I am
I do this full-time the the video stuff
I'm a channel and it's it's pretty
awesome but I used to teach I used to
teach college and university classes
mostly introductory physics astronomy
that sort of thing there's there's a
hierarchy in higher education where like
you're not allowed to teach higher level
classes like even if you could you're
not allowed to unless you have you know
certain degree levels or like certain
you know job seniority or whatever and
so that can get complicated should I do
it should you do a PhD um I I don't
think it's really up to you I mean I
didn't and I didn't want to but there
are some things that you know require it
if you want to be a professor or you
know a practicing scientist or something
like that maybe you know depending on
your field you might need a PhD but I
think that I think that that you know it
really comes down to to what you want
and and I can tell you it's a lot of
stress and a lot of work and so it needs
to be worth it to you you've got to have
that that vision of what you want out of
your life and if you know you need the
PhD to do that then at least you'll have
the motivation to get through
let's see yeah so that's sorry Diana to
leaf we the plan was to have her here
for an hour or so and we got up to five
o'clock because we couldn't get things
to work and I had like the entire chat
calling me and and her boomer but how it
goes I guess we get technology to work
um we we are not boomers just for the
record let's see she's yeah let's see do
do relativity and quantum theories have
a common theory they do not we do not
have a model that puts both them
together we have some attempts but
that's that's about it
let's see got it here
could you explain your path into physics
and computer science
sure so at the beginning of the Q&A here
we were we were talking about our
background um Oh hold on my battery's
gonna die we were back
all sorts technical difficulties today
all right so let's see I actually
started getting into computers when I
was a kid the it was sort of an
up-and-coming thing back then and and so
you know you get your whole family just
kind of like pushing you in a computer
science and pushing you into it and they
always try to have like you know a new
computer around for me to play with my
parents did and um you know so I I got
into it and I was I was into it for a
really long time and then I think I did
a tech support job at some point like
shortly after high school and I hated it
I was miserable doing that I wasn't
stimulated enough I guess and then I
kind of discovered astronomy in physics
and switched switched majors in college
but I started I started college at
Community College with with the intent
of getting a computer science degree
let's see
Wow the number of watching people's
going down while the Diana people have
left let's see
please on soundwaves how is amplitude
does not affect the speed it's kind of a
tricky question to answer in a live
stream kind of neat animations for sound
how do virtual virtual photon exchanges
cause attraction right so this goes back
to what Diana was saying about quantum
fields and like what's happening with
those and it's it's kind of tough to say
there's there's not a lot of intuition
with it but but it it definitely see the
thing is that virtual particles aren't
necessarily real actual particles
they're just particle like things you
know where we a quantum field is doing
some weird you know fluctuation thing
and and it looks kind of like a particle
sometimes but it's it's not really it's
not really like a real particle these
things do not these virtual particles do
not have to obey the laws of physics and
so they're generally considered to be
not real things and so the attraction
happens because of like field energies
and stuff which I would really can't
explain with words but it's very it's
very non-intuitive
maybe maybe one more question and we'll
call it a day this has been this has
been a rough rough livestream session
let's see it's a personal opinion here
do I think the universe will expand
forever I I hate to take a stance on
that that's that I don't know if you go
and based on my feeling I mean I would
have liked the universe to stop
expanding and INRI collapse so that it
would be this like you know cyclical
universe almost kind of like a heartbeat
or something but it doesn't appear to be
the case right if we look at data and
the you know cosmic background and and
that sort of stuff we get we get numbers
that don't
seemed to line up with a cyclical
universe they seem to line up with a
very steadily increasing possibly
accelerating probably accelerating
universe and so based on that we have to
we have to conclude that the universe
will expand forever
there really isn't isn't much argument
against it huh all right so let's see do
physicists use relativistic mass not
really I actually had a conversation
with dr. Lincoln from Fermilab about
this a little while back and the idea is
that like it's a really great
educational tool like when you're first
learning relativity it's using something
like relativistic mass it helps connect
the weirdness of relativity to things
that you know you're more familiar with
like like mass right we're familiar with
what mass does and so it does that right
and it makes the transition into
relativity and learning relativity
pretty easy or I should say easier I
shouldn't say pretty easy it depends on
who you have as a teacher I guess but it
makes it it makes it less stressful but
when you're talking an actual physicist
they don't use relativistic mass in fact
they don't even use mass at all if
you're talking about a particle
physicists particle physicists and its
really stop to say particle physicists
usually say usually you just use energy
instead right and so then we know that
there's there something called rest mass
and then there's all these other
energies and if you want to clump that
all together and call it a relativistic
mass you can but it's not all that
useful for a physicist
um lots of emojis down here I'll see
[Music]
it's got a good question in here I miss
them near the beginning
you
let's see one more question I want to
make it a good one
you
I just got to pick one at this point
don't I
do you miss doing any particular part of
science right so versus research versus
education versus tech or whatever so
we'll go with this one
and so I I don't know that I
I miss it I mean when I was going
through school like Diana did she said
she did the specialization and like
electrical engineering I made sure to
pick the degree that had the fewest labs
as possible I hated doing labs and so
while I acknowledged that labs are very
important they're very important for you
know I should say lab experiments
experiments are very important for
science in general particularly for
physics but I I think that that I don't
I never really liked it and so I tried
to do the more theoretical stuff and I
did I did enjoy doing research on some
mobile I did my master's thesis on white
dwarf stars um and yes I say dwarf I
can't I can't do two dwarf like how do
you do that in one syllable it just
seems awkward to me um I did I did I did
my my thesis on those and the research
for that was kind of stressful but like
I did okay and I still I still get to
research now even doing videos I still
get to research topics I you can't just
put out a video you know willy-nilly
you've got a you've got to be able to
research it in fact check it and make
sure that you're right because you know
people are going to
that people have come to to trust you
you know as a YouTube creator they've
come to trust me and they've come to
trust Diana and and so we have to to
make sure we you know we hold ourselves
to a high standard there and so I do get
to research but I don't I don't miss
experimental techy stuff at all that was
never my my forte all right so I'm gonna
call it here because like I said this
was meant to be you know Diana and I
bouncing stuff off of each other but
maybe I can I can give mister to do this
again and hopefully we'll have we'll
have fewer fewer technical difficulties
next time at least that's the goal right
okay let's see here and so on that note
I will see y'all later hopefully at
least some of you I will see in the
comments and we will hopefully get Diana
or some other physics creed or two to
jump on this thing so in that case be
safe in this this troubling time and
have a good rest of your day